est-ce que cet événement important
évidemment ne tombe pas mal compte tenu
du contexte économique de la
Grande-Bretagne qui quand même politique
et économique dramatique inflation à 14
15 voire 20% un taux de chômage à 20% et
c'est vraiment le moment
de penser des millions de livres
sterling pour le couronnement du roi
alors je vais la corde voilà je veux la
carte de temps que certains disques il a
déjà 75 ans
j'ai envie de vous répondre que oui et
non puisque la BBC vient de nous dire
que elle prévoit un dispositif
exceptionnel on va accrocher plus de 200
caméras sous les voûtes de Westminster
il y en aura tout autant sur le parcours
du couronnement la procession et que ils
attendent bien battre le record
d'Elizabeth I funérailles on rappelle
c'était 4 milliards de téléspectateurs
ceux qui veut donc dire que les
retombées économiques elles sont aussi
énormes alors certes il faut son
couronnement va rapporter autant de blés
on estime déjà que puisque les pays
certains pays vont devoir payer par la
rediffusion des droits à l'image
notamment et que vous imaginez le nombre
de litres de bière qui vont s'écouler
puisqu'il va y avoir des grands déchets
il n'y a quasiment plus aucune place de
libre dont les hôtels déjà maintenant
pour le 6 mai prochain donc certes c'est
le 6 mai on parle environ à de 100
millions de livres c'est le montant qui
circule pour le couronnement et oui
pourquoi parce qu'il y a une grosse
grosse partie plus pour ça être qui vont
être consacrés à la sécurité il faut se
dire que c'est la toute première fois
depuis 70 ans puisque le dernier
couronnement Elisabeth de a eu lieu le 2
juin 1953 que la Tour de Londres va se
séparer pour quelques-uns des joyaux de
la couronne allez fameux les joyaux de
la couronne c'est un Trésor britannique
ça fait partie de l'état alors on parle
de couronne spectaculaire la fameuse
couronne de Saint-Édouard celle qui fait
les rois
c'est la même que c'est la même couronne
que sa mère alors elle elle elle sait
que sa fameuse cour que l'on aperçoit
elle ne peut être portée par les
souverains qu'une seule fois le jour de
son couronnement elle sera pourtant au
moment où il va y avoir ce qu'on appelle
l'onction en fait c'est quoi c'est comme
c'est on vous la prête on voulait
reprendre absolument mais il y aura
trois couronnes il ne va pas arriver
avec la même couronne et il ne va pas
repartir avec la même couronne il
repartira avec la couronne d'apparaître
c'est tout des bisous ça c'est tout
c'est tout du vrai ça
c'est absolument tout tout vrai oui il y
en a pour des millions là c'est ce qu'on
visite
à chiffrable c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que la grosse partie en gros
[Musique]
c'est là dedans que vont être par
l'apothicaire Royal que va être déversé
quelques gouttes d'huile sainte qui
auront été préparées qui vont être
déversées dans la cuillère que vous
voyez qui date de 1200 et c'est avec ça
qu'il va avoir l'onction
et sur le visage mais vous voyez
également regarder les deux sceptre le
sceptre à la colombe que l'on voit là et
le sceptre l'autre sceptre le sceptre à
la croix et il était déjà posé sur cette
rue là vous vous souvenez sur le
cercueil lors des funérailles ça c'est
un gros diamant celui-là là le truc là
c'est un gros diamant ça c'est l'étoile
d'Afrique ça veut dire quoi c'est le
deuxième plus gros diamant du monde
sachant que le premier et bien il est
sur une broche je ne suis pas sûr que
l'on voit là il y a les bracelets les
deux bracelets qui vont lui être remis
lors de la cérémonie
donc la cérémonie d'Elisabeth II
Benjamin avait duré 3 ans la charlotte
III nous dit qu'il veut une cérémonie un
peu simplifiée elle va durer une heure
et demie mais en effet tous les symboles
que vous voyez là il y a encore qui ne
sont pas tous représentés vont lui être
remis en a un durant cette cérémonie on
dit que Charles III est déjà en train de
répéter maintenant
c'est l'arche
vertical que l'on salue qui parle en
français parfait et qui est propriétaire
d'une maison en Normandie d'ailleurs
Justin Wilm
officier avec le Chaplin de Will
smithsters
et il sera aussi en charge de la
sexualité ils seront tous présents ils
seront tous présents c'est juste
question il y a le monde entier à tous
les chefs d'État vont venir mais donc là
c'est une question pour le coup qu'on
sait si on veut être plus royaliste que
le roi et que l'on se réfère vous savez
90% de la population mondiale n'a jamais
connu de couronnement d'un roi
d'Angleterre il faut remonter à ça qu'en
3 et bien ça quand trois on constate
qu'il n'y avait quasiment aucun chef
d'État qui était présent sous les voûtes
de Westminster pour la cérémonie de
couronnement d'Elizabeth II alors
techniquement un chef d'État ne peut pas
assister j'ai un cadeau pour vous je
sais que vous aimez beaucoup la reine
pépé à son âme et on a un cadeau j'ai
des images du couronnement ah je pense
qu'elles sont pas très cher c'est dans
les oreilles pas regardé
au moment où sous les yeux de ces deux
enfants la reine Elizabeth dans toute sa
majesté sort du palais de Buckingham 10
millions de citoyens britanniques et un
demi million de visiteurs étrangers
s'apprêtent à lui faire un triomphe
comme on envie jamais
[Applaudissements]
on peut la mettre des des boules Quies
sont blancs ou pas ils seront gris il
sera gris Winsor Grey très exactement
c'est un gris Winsor un peu couleur de
poussière si l'on peut dire pour qu'on a
attendu autant de temps parce que
la reine
le but
respecter une période de deuil et
surtout surtout le duc de Norfolk c'est
le premier personnage de la cour quand
on dit de Queen's dead low god save the
king ah mais il est devenu roi
directement seconde Elizabeth Marc il
devient quoi mais il n'est pas couronné
le couronnement c'est quoi dans le fond
Benjamin on rappelle que si les chefs de
l'église anglicane à partir du moment où
il va être roi du verbe goivre ouindre
où on va lui remettre
que je vous aime très loin on va lui
déposer les huiles il va devenir si on
respecte la tradition
lieutenant de Dieu sur terre c'est à
dire pour les anglicans il est la
représentation de Dieu c'est à partir de
ce moment-là Benjamin qu'il devient
intouchable on ne peut plus toucher le
roi puisque est en relation de Dieu on
ne touche on ne touche pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
voilà
je je je mets dans le dans le lit de du
roi d'un ensemble les deux quand même
75 ans mon lit
à mon avis Charlot il doit y aller
peut-être comme à l'époque vous savez à
l'époque comment on faisait pour
justement respecter le respect de la
femme ce qui est légal c'était un drap
il y avait un
troue
avec un trou ouais pourquoi le trou j'ai
compris
Camilla j'aime pas beaucoup non personne
ne l'aime hein
est-ce que du coup sort elle va être
reine
là c'est quelle couronne va-t-elle
coiffer alors une couronne aussi
elle porte un diamant à leur
spectaculaire et célébrissime qui est le
casino
il est il est revendiqué par l'Inde où
l'un des dit que dans le fond et bah les
Anglais leur ont volé ce diamant
bien sûr
une attaque totalement
donc il est pas prêt 12 vous vous doutez
bien que s'il avait vraiment d'accord
donc là donc là la reine qu'on sort va
être reine en fait voilà mais ils
pourront plus toucher
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ce
couronnement fondament par rapport à
l'état actuel parce que là il est roi il
est roi l'autre là sinon ça ne va non
techniquement qu'est-ce que ça va
vraiment changer dans le quotidien dans
le fond des Anglais du monde non ça ne
va rien changer du tout
une couronne sur la tête tout le temps
mais non il me rappelle une confiance
sur la tête tout le temps non non il
aurait une couronne quand il va arriver
il aurait une couronne
quand la cérémonie la fameuse couronne
de Salvador il aurait une couronne maman
de repartir il a pas plus de couronnette
pour mettre dans la maison
c'est le roi carré voilà j'ai ma
couronne
le truc
nous parviennent tous les jours et nous
montre à quel point l'Angleterre et le
monde sont en train de se passionner
pour cette journée alors certes t'as pas
coûté un peu d'argent comme vous par
exemple la presse a déjà rebaptisé le
jour du couronnement le Cid le corones
et aujourd'hui 27 janvier ben on
décompte on est précisément à 99 jours
de ce corones
et moi jusqu'au 6 mai je suis comme ça
alors est-ce qu'il y a des choses
maintenant qui les rois qui pourra plus
faire
non non pipi dans la neige techniquement
sa vie a vraiment basculé le jour à la
minute où Elisabeth II est morte est
décédé vous avez deux jours plus tard il
a été proclamé dans le fond à partir du
moment où il est proclamé roi sur le
papier il est déjà souverain il règne
déjà cette cérémonie c'est juste du
spectacle en quelque sorte c'est
l'occasion de sortir bah c'est joyaux
qui n'ont plus sorti de puissance et de
faire le chef de l'Église anglicane ce
n'est que ça c'est le côté religieux en
réalité
je vous rappelle qu'on parle de la
journée du 6 mai mais c'est tout à
weekend puisque le 7 et le 8 mai il va
également parce que c'est comme ça il
est parti en concert gigantesque
de façon à se différencier du jubilé
vous souhaitez il y avait un énorme
concert qui avait été donné devant la
façade de Buckingham celui-ci va avoir
lieu à Windsor au château de Windsor
plus vaste château du monde
oh c'est énorme c'est c'est plus timide
pièces le chariotisme
planétaire international évidemment
évidemment elle te donne alors est-ce
qu'ils sont payés quand ils viennent ces
gens-là est-ce qu'ils sont absolument
pas
normalement non ils le font pour le roi
et le prestige 4 milliards de
qui sont les rois ou prince
d'inviter alors ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est le duc de Norval qui est
en charge de l'organisation celui qui
vient en France celui qui vient un petit
chaton
la liste des invités maintenant la vraie
question c'est est-ce que les chefs
d'État l'assisteront ou pas je vous ai
dit en 53 il y avait pas de chef d'État
normalement non mais on sait très bien
que Charles le 3 vœux du nouveau veut
une cérémonie un peu plus contemporaine
un peu plus moderne et qu'il a de réels
liens d'amitié avec des chefs d'État
dont notamment Emmanuel Macron donc il
se pourrait peut-être que en effet des
chefs d'État assiste à cette cérémonie
d'accord j'ai une question là parce
qu'il a attendu très longtemps quand
même pour devenir roi il en rêvait ou
pas lui parce qu'il était un peu le rêve
non il est un peu le rebelle de la
famille aussi avec Lamia il voulait il
trouvait que c'était parce que là
carrément qu'il a poussé la vidéo alors
ça c'est ça
et établi à tel point même que le Palais
a demandé et obtenu le fait que
désormais sur cette cinquième saison
apparaît ceci est une fiction alors que
sur les autres il n'y avait pas ce
bandeau là c'est bien qu'ils prennent de
grandes liberté the clone
donc c'est pas que j'aime pas ça comme
si si j'adore ce comme c'est génial
j'adore ce que vous savez pourquoi pour
l'atmosphère pour les décors ça c'est
purement
quand on prend vraiment le centre de
regarder ils prennent quand même de très
grands libertés à un moment donné pour
revenir à la question on estimait qu'il
souhaitait voilà vraiment devenir roi en
disant mais je peux apporter de la
modernité un petit peu un coup de jaune
et que sur les dernières années
de nouveau il a été il a été un peu
audio au début parce que j'ai là le
stylo il râle parce qu'il y a pas de le
ciel
ça fait depuis qu'il est tout petit on
lui dit un jour tu seras roi de cette
galaxie
regardez les images regardez de
température
[Musique]
ils ont habité à Windsor ils ont
vraiment l'embarras du chaud
52000 52 mm carré la bico comment il a
dit là quand même hein
est-ce que est-ce que le roi en tant que
roi est un salaire est-ce que le roi en
tant que enfant oui absolument payer
c'est compliqué oui
c'est pas un salaire c'est une c'est une
enveloppe si vous voulez qui lui est
remise annuellement et dans le coup dans
lequel d'emploi il fait ce qu'il veut
avec cette enveloppe là en tout cas il
va distribuer ce montant c'est du cash
c'est du cash
complètement bancaire
à qui il va redistribuer parce que on
rappelle que
le montant exactement
ou pas et alors c'est soumis à la peau
absolument depuis l'incendie du château
twinsor en 1992 pas qu'ils ont payé un
peu les travaux ah parce que le chat de
Minecraft incroyable en effet la reine
ne voulait pas payer les travaux et puis
tu comptes fait il y a eu une levée de
boucliers et puis ça leur fait qui est à
la grande question quel va être le rôle
de William il est désormais
s'ils étaient Miss France Charles il
serait dauphin en effet oui William il
est bien en fait voilà son premier job
ça va être quoi ça va être dès que le
roi va avoir le 6 mai la couronne de
saint-étoile sur la tête il va être le
premier à s'agenouiller devant son
croire
William prince de Galles je me remets à
vous je suis désormais votre serviteur
votre homme lit je va-t-il dire quitte à
y laisser la vie quitte à gagner la mort
que Dieu me sauve dans cette mission qui
m'est donnée ça devient donc le premier
homme du royaume il devient
très très traditionnel et ça remonte au
fond des âges et en effet la toute
première cérémonie courement le calme
que de cette cérémonie elle date de 1066
ça n'a pas été quasiment le même calque
pas envie de Guillaume la conquérir
alors la grande question se pose
évidemment la question c'est est-ce que
Harry
est-ce qu'il est invité pour l'instant
Harry et son bouquin il a mis le bordel
quand même
il parait que c'est un carton un peu le
bouquin c'est ça
10 millions de livres ont été en tout
cas mis en place pas
en place il a touché c'est que l'argent
vous intéresse
80 millions de dollars il a déjà 80
millions de dollars absolument
ou pas tu gardes la valoir moi
mais est-ce qu'il va de nous dire que à
la relecture de ce livre qui fait quand
même 500 pages dans sa version française
il en avait supprimé plus de 300 qui
estimait que les 300 pages j'étais un
petit peu trop virulente par rapport à
son père
sous le pied et que c'est le tome 2 donc
je ne sais pas justement parce que je
mets de la gueule une négociation je me
demande
et si justement à l'inverse de ce que
l'on pourrait croire il ne souhaiterait
pas être sous les voûtes de Westminster
si ils ne sont pas présents
donc dire aux yeux du monde entier je
vous rappelle 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs Mégane elle adore ça les
actrices ça et bien non elle tombe plus
à mettre de péloche non non mais ça
voudrait donc dire qu'ils ont quitté le
giron Royal le cercle
pour la famille
mais je vous disais qu'on apprend des
nouvelles tous les jours et la dernière
nouvelle que l'on apprend voyez vous
c'est qu'une grande chaîne américaine
CBS pour ne pas la nommer vient de faire
une proposition au prince Harry à 7
chiffres dit-on pour commenter la
cérémonie de Renoir
il est né le cul dans le beurre il fait
encore de l'oseille avec tout ça
j'espère pour lui sa carrière qu'il
acceptera pas le poste et qui sera au
courant de son papa parce que sinon ça
serait ça serait ça serait quand même on
dit on dit que malgré tout cet argent il
paraît que le couple ils sont ils sont
pas bien non non alors c'est pas qu'ils
sont pas bien je vous assure que ils
sont très très subtils j'ai étudié
justement la chose récemment ils font
des placements qui sont ultra judicieux
on ne le sait pas forcément voyez-vous
même sur Mégane Markle plus que Harry
d'ailleurs elle a acheté des parts dans
une société de café de café américain
et bien et ça lui rapporte énormément
d'argent et on estime que la maison vous
savez qu'ils ont acheté à montechit bien
amène tes chips
petite montagne c'est de Los Angeles
c'est très beau c'est l'endroit le plus
cher c'est l'endroit des milliards
ils l'ont acheté 7 millions de dollars
et Elsa non elle vient d'être évalué à
case qui ne sont passés par là qu'on les
a vu on a vu cette maison dans le monde
entier et que donc ils ont l'art de
faire de bons placements toute l'année
pas trop de crade pour les gens je peux
aider ben parce que
[Applaudissements]
pas faire un bouquin par exemple
j'ai étudié un peu l'histoire et ça m'a
fait beaucoup de peine en fait il
semblerait que le service de presse des
frères
et de la famille royale en fait jouer
avec la presse et donner des infos
plutôt que d'autres et que la balance
était plutôt du côté de William pour
enfant
et je trouve ça dégueulasse en fait oui
mais
il n'y a pas de contrepo il y a pas de
contre paroles
par son père et qui donnait des biscuits
mais voilà tu vas dire que ils ont fait
ça comme ça tu parles pas de ça est-ce
que c'est vrai tellement
ce serait plutôt Camille ce serait
plutôt les équipes de Camilla qui en
effet ont voulu redorer l'image de
Camila auprès de la presse et on dit à
la presse on va vous vendre un peu de la
matière et de biscuit si vous acceptez
un peu de présenter Camilla sous un jour
qui paraîtrait voilà mais c'est normal
c'est dégueulasse
c'est normal
le roi
non
si casse la pipe demain qui devient roi
pas les enfants c'est pas ça descendance
le système Royal ce n'est pas une
famille comme les autres je ne cesse de
le répéter une seule personne compte
c'est le souverain et son héritier
direct les autres ne comptent pas
humainement les Windsor qui sont pas
géniaux je l'avoue je suis le premier à
le dire et il y a et il y a en effet des
c'est plus que des bruits de couloir
donc ce serait le petit George ce serait
le fils de
williami
je vous allez y aller le 6 mai
[Rires]
merci beaucoup